je voudrais revenir sur quelque chose
qui fait énormément parler
croyez vous à la théorie du complot
alors samedi
il ya une étude de l'ifop qui a révélé
que plus d'un français plus d'un quart
des français pensent que le coronavirus
avec est fabriqué en laboratoire 26 %
des gens c'est assez énorme vous allez
voir que le chiffre bondit pour
certaines catégories de population dans
un instant on va faire un point sur
toutes les théories du complot qu'on a
pu lire autour du coronavirus on en
parlera également avec jérôme fourquet
le directeur de l'ifop qui a sorti ce
sondage et avec thomas huchon qu'on aime
beaucoup qui ne reviendra là-dessus qui
va nous dire parce que c'est vrai qu'il
ya plein de gens qui disent que c'est
vrai que c'est fait que on comprend pas
est-ce que vous croyez à la théorie du
complot vous gilbert days vont vous y
croyez ou pas oui alors je ne rejoins
pas les thèses qui sont souvent celles
de l'extrême droite du tout ça vous le
savez mais le virus il vient d'où il
vient de ce virus ont dit viens d'un
animal on est incapable de le prouver
donc moi oui je fais partie de ces 25 %
de français qui pense que peut-être qui
s'est échappé d'un laboratoire
involontairement mais peut-être qu'on
nous cache des choses et peut-être qu'on
apprendra dans dix ans d'où il vient
donc je crois que nous cache des choses
et quand on croit qu'on nous cache des
choses
ça s'appelle un complot il ya peut-être
bien un couple aussi riche alors avant
de voir quels sont les cinq demandés
sont plus haut qui ont été le plus
partagé
je voudrais qu'on écoute marine le pen
qui était ce matin sur france info et
pourrait le gouvernement surtout donc
elles seraient là dessus regardez début
de cette crise il ya eu une stratégie du
gouvernement qui a consisté en réalité à
cacher le niveau de faiblesse de l'état
de nos stocks
le niveau d'impréparation de notre pays
plutôt que de dire la vérité et
embarqués si je te permettent dans ce
mensonge est bien celui ci on a entraîné
d'autres tout au long des semaines qui
me l'a séparé de la prise de conscience
de
la gravité de cette crise ça a commencé
par les frontières puis ça continue avec
les masques étaient soi-disant inutile
et puis les tests qui étaient eux mêmes
soient des gens inutiles et tout cela si
vous voulez a créé une situation de
méfiance
évidemment de la part de la population à
l'égard de ceux des dirigeantes
dirigeants alors on va revenir sur les
cinq théorie du complot
les plus partagées le 1 c'est le virus a
été créé en laboratoire comme vous
disait gilles verdez les personnalités
riches créerait des virus dans les
laboratoires pour réduire la population
car on serait beaucoup trop sur la
planète comme pour le sida qui aurait
été créé par un scientifique américain
le covin 19 auraient été créés aux états
unis en 2003 sur une publication
facebook qui a été énormément partager
on peut lire que le coronavirus est une
création du monde breveté en 2003 auprès
des autorités américaines
je découvre que le coronavirus n'est pas
nouveau il a été créé en 2003 aux
etats-unis que bizarrement quelques
choses devraient se passer
ce 24 janvier 2020 sauf que tout huit
des neuf n'est donc pas le seul
coronavirus et le brevet dont parle
cette publication concerne un autre
virus le strass regardez cette vidéo
d'antonio que je connais bien entretenu
c'est un gilet jaune qui venaient nous
voir sur le plateau lui il pense qu'on
est dans le complot regardez il a fait
une vidéo d'une vingtaine de minutes qui
a fait énormément parler la semaine
dernière et il a prouvé à sa manière que
le co en avions russes avaient été créés
en laboratoire brevets à l'appui
regarder ça 2003 on trouve des traces
d'un fascicule d'un brevet européen
oui vous avez bien entendu j'ai un
fascicule dans les mains
comme quoi il y à bien un brevet
européen indiquant nouvelle souche de
corrado virus d'accord associé aux
strass et à ses applications
le moulin brodeur le voilà le problème
voilà ce qu'on trouve nous tuer
aujourd'hui vous commencez sur la
première page on trouve les inventeurs
inventeur j'insiste inventeur ils ont
inventé
d'accord ils ont pris deux virus
tout est indiqué entre regarde alors il
ya thomas bichon qui nous a rejoint
qu'on va à qui on va parler dans
l'instant alors dans sa vidéo il avait
également accusé d' institut pasteur
il a répondu très clairement dans une
vidéo démontrant que c'était pour eux
une fait qu'ils regardent en 2004
l'institut pasteur a déposé un brevet
qui ne concernait pas l'invention d'un
nouveau virus
le brevet au contraire concernés le
dépôt de ces camps ce qui correspondait
au coronavirus numéro un qui a causé le
sarce ce que nous avions fait à l'époque
c'est déposer ces séquences pour pouvoir
les utiliser pour mettre au point des
candidats vaccins et maintenant nous
utilisons notre savoir-faire acquis à
l'époque pour mettre au point un nouveau
candidat vaccin contre le sarc
coronavirus de qui circulent
actuellement dans le monde
alors ya jérôme rodriguez stream
allemands sms vous savez mon mon pote un
giro voilà comment voix sms qu'il dit
salut cyril je viens défendre mon pote
antonio il est regrettable que la
deuxième vidéo qu'il a publiés n'ai pas
fait le même buzz où il s'explique un
peu plus voilà je voulais le défendre
tout simplement je t'embrasse montre ton
parce qu'ils seront très chères et c'est
très compliqué le pauvre il est pris
dans la tourmente
on mettra la deuxième vidéo demain on va
on va se la procurer et ce matin marine
le pen a affirmé sur france info que
c'était une question de bon sens que le
fait de se demander si le virus a été
créé en laboratoire ou pas on va en
parler dans un instant avec thomas ion
est un professeur également regarder ce
qu a dit marine le pen
c'était les gens s'interrogent pour
savoir si ce virus est d'origine entre
email naturel ou s'il ne peut pas avoir
échappé d'un laboratoire est une
question qui me paraît est une question
de bon sens quand est ce que ça ne te
parle pas non non moi je n'ai encore je
n'ai aucune opinion sur ces sujets mais
dans l'histoire
je sais parce que j'essaye de ne pas
l'être à culte je sais qu'un certain
nombre de maladies ont échappé des
laboratoires comme la myxomatose par
exemple bon tout ce sont des choses qui
arrivent thèmes sont strictement rien la
situation actuelle nous sommes en effet
nettement à l'origine du virus
hélas elle n'a aucune influence sur ce
que nous sommes en train de vivre
on verra dans un instant les théories du
complot vous allez voir les quatre
autres théories du complot qui sont
développés sont complètement folle vous
poser une question les chéris c'est vrai
que ça fait qu' énormément réagir sur le
coronavirus c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens voilà merci à franck tapiro
d'être avec nous merci comme actions qui
vont nous éclairer
bien entendu la vie là dessus et aux
missions qui est spécialiste des faits
que nous disons qu'il va nous dire tout
ce qui se passe croyez vous à la théorie
du complot puisqu'il ya un sondage qui
est sortie 26 % des gens et c'est énorme
voilà pour pense que le corona virus a
été fabriqué en laboratoire
alors on va en parler dans un instant
donc avec thomas bichon et avec franck
tapiro et avec toute notre équipe
regardez petite vidéo récapitulative et
je vous donnerai les quatre autres
théories du complot qui sont sortis vous
allez voir c'est complètement fou
regardez c'est parti le sujet autour de
la naissance du coronavirus obsède toute
la population et de fait face au manque
de preuves les théories les plus folles
autour de l'apparition du coït 19 se
multiplient d'après les chercheurs
l'origine de ce virus viendrait de la
consommation de viande avariée
probablement de pangolin et de
chauves-souris d'un marché insalubre de
la ville de wuhan en chine mais si cette
version officielle est une piste
beaucoup pensent que la vérité est
ailleurs
selon une étude de l'ifop les français
seraient même 26 % à penser que le virus
a été créé en laboratoire
si certains pensent qu'il a été créée de
façon accidentelle les français sont
tout de même 17 % à être convaincu que
cela a été fait intentionnellement dans
le but de contaminer massivement des
populations des chiffres qui monte même
à 40 % des personnes convaincues chez
les sympathisants du rassemblement
national alors que plusieurs
publications sur internet ont fait le
buzz récemment en tentant de prouver que
le corona virus était bel et bien une
création de s'avancer même article avait
été démontée par la communauté
scientifique qui a exposé les failles de
ce raisonnement complotistes toujours
est il que les américains eux aussi sont
nombreux à suivre la piste du complot
là-bas 27 % des moins de 35 ans pense
que le virus a été développée
intentionnellement les chiffres qui
forcent à se poser des questions sur ce
virus ravageur dont on ne sait
aujourd'hui toujours pas grand chose et
vous croyez-vous à ces théories du
complot
croyez-vous à ces théories du complot
merci à frans de capitaux des pleins
merci à thomas husson alors on va donner
les quatre théorie du complot alors on
l'a donnée à la première c'est donc que
ce virus était fabriqué en laboratoire
il ya une autre théorie israël et les
juifs à la manoeuvre de nombreux
extrémistes et conspirationnistes le
russes ont diffusé des vidéos et des
documents largement relayé sur les
réseaux sociaux dans lesquels il a bien
que le virus aurait été créé par les
juifs en israël pour accroître leur
contrôle sur le monde et en tirer profit
voilà ça c'est ce qu'on a c'est ce qu'on
a vu en 3d à la chloroquine ne rapporte
pas assez au gouvernement
donc voilà en parlant de chloroquine il
faut dire que depuis que le professeur
homme affirme avoir trouvé un traitement
contre le coronavirus les théories du
complot se multiplient ya ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut être prudent et qu'il
faut réaliser tous les essais cliniques
nécessaires avant de prescrire les
médicaments et d'autres qui pensent
qu'il faut la prescrire tout de suite et
sur internet on voit beaucoup de
messages affirmant que la presse essaie
de faire passer professeur raoult pour
un fou que le gouvernement refuse
d'utiliser la chloroquine car le
traitement ne rapporterait pas assez
d'argent
il ya une autre théorie du complot les
antennes 5 j'ai pointé du doigt hué à
lui a donc fait partie des villes qui
expérimente la 5g des radiations
affaiblir et les défenses immunitaires
et donc ce serait la raison pour
laquelle le virus serait partie de l'ue
and voilà les théories qu'on entend et
enfin la cinquième théorie du complot
qu'on entend c'est la faute à bill gates
et à la cia
on a dit il ya une rumeur qui a été
reprise partout dans le monde le virus
aurait été créée par bill gates
missionné par la cia voilà il faut
rappeler que bill gates le fondateur de
microsoft qui a une fondation qui
finance des recherches sur les vaccins
donc son plan serait de diffuser le
coronavirus en chine pour réduire la
population et faire travailler sa
fondation pour trouver un vaccin pour
guérir les personnes qu'il souhaite et
s'attirer tout les goûts manche partout
dans le monde
alors voilà alors c'est vrai qu'on
entend tout et n'importe quoi qui y
croit à la théorie du complot et il
tomba huchon
et bien sûr le cas stan était crois pas
du tout à part de moi je pense que la
seule chose qui auquel on peut croire
c'est qu'effectivement le corps d'amy
eux c'est comme tchernobyl
au début on nous a dit ça va s'arrêter à
la frontière française là je pense
effectivement on est tous d'accord là
dessus c'est que voilà on a menti sur sa
après le reste le compositeur absolument
pas mr pas du tout il me permettait
d'intervenir cyril car déjà je suis ravi
que que ce qu'on est on a passé
plusieurs émissions ensemble avec
benjamin donc c'est bien qu'ils soient
sur la ligne mais par contre sur
tchernobyl on a tous l'impression qu'on
nous a menti à l'époque mais c'est pas
vrai regardez sur le site de l'ina les
jt de l'époque il y avait une prévention
et tous et cette histoire qu'on nous a
menti pour tchernobyl s'est pas
totalement vrai je crois qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe en ce moment
qui est à la fois très inquiétant et en
même temps qu'on peut expliquer on est
face à un phénomène qu'on comprend pas
et donc imaginer que quelqu'un en est le
responsable à la suite au que ça soit
quelque chose qu'on n'arrive pas à
comprendre c'est grave mais c'est moins
grave que quelque chose qu'on comprend
pas du tout la juste revenir sur ce que
tout à l'heure
madame le pen a dit qu'elle avait du bon
sens de se poser la créature je crois
qu'elle a surtout du sens politique
c'est vrai que le tournage qui a était
paru ce week-end et qui dit 25 % des
français pensent que le virus ait été
créé en laboratoire
il dit aussi que 40 % des gens qui
votent front national parce que le virus
a été créé en laboratoire nous quand tu
es sahel parle avant tout à sa base
politique plutôt que de chercher à
informer les français dans un moment de
crise grave
et bah elle cherche à faire sa petite
magouille politique je suis pas certain
que ça soit laquelle brille le plus
alors franck tapiro kate avec tous merci
franck des plats spéciaux de la
communication qu'on a dollar en restant
penses toi
j'emporte c'est un truc simple c'est que
la nature a horreur du vide et pour que
le rendu vidéo c'est qu'il ya des villes
dont celle de le combler il se passe
quelque chose de dingue c'est que
personne ne sait rien finalement
il faut avouer personne ne sait rien
aujourd'hui scientifiquement il ya passé
le recul on voit bien que il y a les
probabilités il ya certaines personnes
qui ont les opinions on ne sait
pratiquement rien voilà pourquoi le
timing
bouge sans arrêt on est quinze jours
ensuite qu'un jour normal c'est normal
on comme il ya un vide énorme sérieux de
données scientifiques
ah ben ça laisse sa place à tous et
d'une hurluberlus que c'est fou qui
commence à sortir tous les vieux cons
cient sont israël et les juifs dont 37
protocole des sages de sion
malheureusement fait un siècle qu'on
pense que je vais pouvoir surtout après
on dit que évidemment ça va être pour
supprimer
à quelques semaines de la loi contre les
retraites sur les mails air trapping si
j'en ai un gendre lui tous les jours des
horreurs pareilles voix savoir que le
cerveau humain est ainsi fait
malheureusement quand il n'y a pas à
dire de données officielles quand il ya
un vide le cerveau ne commence est
malheureusement hyper créatif mais dans
le mauvais sens où on avant tout et
n'importe quoi pourquoi parce qu'il ya
une audience ceci comme vous le savez
très bien élite à l'heure du jeu quand
il n'ya pas de parole officielle les
gens sont contents d'entendre n'importe
quoi il faut un coupable
il faut une solution il faut absolument
trouver le pourquoi du comment
voilà comment le phénomène des rumeurs
le phénomène des complots interviennent
depuis de nombreuses années il ya même
aujourd'hui des gens qui pensent que la
terre est plate l'avez vu il ya monsieur
de jeu on va s'appeler non celle qui
veut agir là dessus s'il vous plaît au
tour de berne à montrem lundi cette
théorie du complot c'est systématique je
vois lady di ont peu pas supporté
qu'elle soit morte bêtement donc c'est
un complot notre dame de paris c'est un
complot ces théories du complot d'abord
s on s en sont mauvais c'est nous et
avons à la fois ya du fond de racisme
c'est assez pénible quand on part
d'israël c'est honteux de plessé supposé
ça je crois qu'à chaque fois les gens
ont besoin de pointer du doigt pour se
rassurer de trouver un coupable très
vite et tout de suite
simplement pour se rassurer donc on est
prêt à accepter n'importe quelle
connerie évidemment cas aucun complot
dans cette histoire et je crois que le
temps n'est pas venu aux polémiques
minutes plus tôt au temps de guérison de
soigner les gens est de rester ensemble
unis gilles gilles verdez qui est pas
d'accord ils public et bien sûr qu'on
bernardi à des complots odieux bien sûr
tout cela il faut l'ailé n'est pas dire
l'ailé les jeter c'est horrible mais si
c'est une théorie du complot de dire que
la science n'est pas capable de savoir
d'où vient ce virus qui envahit le monde
entier oratoire chinois eh bien il ya
une mauvaise manipulation qui l'a fait
fuir
ça veut dire ça j'ai mes carnets octas
pire on me disait nature ou avoir dû
ville d'accord mais cqfd
c'est peut-être pas invitant c'est
peut-être un mauvais laborantins chinois
qu'elle et ses chapelles bien mais
qu'est ce que vous en savez vous ne
faites des technologies prennent ben
ouais mais comment tu peux rien vous
avez qu'est ce que vous en savez un
rouleau là il ya une seule certitude il
ya beaucoup de voix là il ya beaucoup de
zones d'ombré dans cette histoire de
corona dit aussi à une seule certitude
sur laquelle s'entendent tous les
scientifiques c'est l'origine animale du
gyrus et là encore tu plus la théorie
complot encore plus loin c'est une
certitude
partant de cette certitude à chaque
épidémie par le passé il ya eu une
théorie du complot
c'est d'ailleurs toujours les mêmes
coupables en général via la cia et les
juifs dans la dans la combine des mois
jean-claude loin aux complotistes co2 ni
complotistes comme des rebelles ou à
avoir été honoré cei soit de les noter
une petite singularité en faire entendre
sa voix soit 2 en tirer vraiment ofi
politique
je voulais faire les fous complotistes
face à celle un complot attendent si
c'est un complot le mec 4 comploter sa
folle nommait le roi du monde qui tue
parce que la carte est là qu est ce qui
fait marcher le monde
l'argent le sexe des religions le mec il
a mis les trois qui consomme elle d'un
coup comme ça il a un talent est un
nouveau pour les champs elysées il ya
des canards il a tué la finance on n'est
pas fournie ans ferme et chez nous on a
toujours dit qu est ce que vous feriez
qu'il faut rester 24 heures à vivre
ouais j'irai la grl a géré la résultante
des comptes chez nous à acheter du fait
qu le même si le complot non mais on me
donne la couronne et moi je me prosterne
devant lui sert il je vais m'appuyer sur
vous vous êtes un vaisseau scientifique
vous êtes maurice scientifique analyse
du bon ça démarre très alors ça démarre
très mal alors là on n'est pas bien là
les mecs vas-y
hall on nous disait les scientifiques
sur les anneaux c'est le papa c'est vrai
c'est vrai j'aimerais taumalolo nous
disait ça vient tout le monde le
reconnaît d'un animal oui mais c'est
faux
cyril regardez vous qui êtes féru de
tout ça est ce que ça vient d'une souris
et elle change de main au collet est ce
que ça vient d'un autre animal et bien
leur être pas que ça dure et ça non non
non non mais gilles schyle sur ça tout
le monde dit que c'est d'oser d'origine
animale mais même voilà les médecins
qu'on a eue ils disent on sait pas
exactement de quel animal on parle oui
chauve-souris on parle d'un autre animal
etc
thomas c'est vrai ça tendent à innover
oui messieurs surtout choix qui il
faudrait pas opposer la tante d'une
réponse scientifique qui est nécessaire
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de temps pour
trouver tous ces éléments et des choses
qui sont nourris
n'hésitez pas du tout c'est la position
de monsieur verdez mai mais il faudrait
pas mélanger des choses qui sont nourris
par une haine préalable à des questions
scientifiques qui sont bien légitimes
regardez ce qui se passe en ce moment
tous les intégristes religieux soit en
train de voir dans le virus le
responsable de son ennemi les les
intégristes musulmans disent que c'est
un coup des sionistes
les intégristes juifs disent que c'est
un coup des chrétiens et des intégristes
évangélistes dispersé d'un coup que ça
va frapper que les synagogues
parce que les juifs ont lesté crucifié
le christ finalement je crains que dans
une période de crise comme celle qu'on
vient maintenant et raymond le disait
très bien chacun voit son ennemi et
chacun va se servir de la crise pour
attaquer son ennemi et quelques pages
sur la tête donner un conseil à tous les
gens qui nous regardent quand vous voyez
passer un message sur les réseaux
sociaux ou sur vos wac ça parce que
maintenant les gens rient ils iraient
envoient des messages parlent de ça
posez vous la question qui est ce qu'on
essaye de me faire détester est en fait
en posant une question les rames et ben
vous arriverez certainement à voir
l'orientation de ce message et à
comprendre que la personne qui vous
parle veux pas vous informer sur une
question elle peut vous rallier à sa
cause pour vous trouver un ennemi
et dans les réseaux sociaux cette
dynamique elle marche très très bien
donc posez vous la question quand vous
voyez passer un message qui est ce qu'on
essaie alors de faire j'étais thomas
trop nar et toma tout le monde sur la je
vous dis le sondage vous allez voir les
résultats du sondage sur cette question
il ils sont et le sondage de voir le
résultat
il est vraiment étonnant mais étonnant
alors ya plein de gens qui réagissent
sur twitter qu'ils disent un soi-disant
virus apparaît comme par hasard ou chine
faut bien se poser des questions tmp mpf
est bien juste fait juste bien
s'informer de soi même et des théories
du complot s'effondre vite tabac je
crois à une théorie ou la chine aurait
voulu baisser le taux de natalité après
la loi de deux enfants c'est n'importe
quoi ces rumeurs de toute façon chaque
maladie on croit que c'est un complot
normal de penser ça on nous manque
tellement
qu'est ce que vous lui tu as à thomas
husson voilà vous mais je pense que tous
ces gens qui s'intéressent qui
s'interrogent ils ont raison de se poser
des questions de toute façon peut pas
empêcher les gens se poser des questions
le problème c'est que quand on se pose
des questions sur internet
eh ben c'est google qui donne la réponse
et google
il vous donne pas la meilleure réponse
il vous donne la réponse qu'elle a pu
partager qu'elle a plus vu qu est la
plus polémique et par exemple si on pose
la question à google est ce que la terre
est plate
ou est ce que la terre est ronde bah
google va vous dire que la terre est
plate parce que tous les gens qui
pensent que la terre est plate écrivent
et produit beaucoup plus de messages que
tous ceux qui pensent que la terre est
ronde
donc je crois qu'il faut faire très
attention là dessus le problème c'est
pas de se poser des questions et encore
une fois tous les téléspectateurs ont eu
le droit
ils ont raison de s'interroger le
problème c'est que ils trouveront
beaucoup plus de réponses sérieuses et
les réponses sérieuses cyril je suis
désolé de vous le dire comme ça mais
elles sont chiantes elles sont pas sexy
elle est la rampe à rêver elles font pas
un clic sur youtube elles font pas un
clic
elle serait pas invité dans votre
émission ce que je veux dire c'est mon
pack wii cela donne c'est que vient il
ya un moment où c'est aussi le problème
de l'internet
on est tous confinés chez nous on peut
plus parler on entend et on entend plein
d'autres conneries je vous dire d'autres
théories du complot qu'on a entendu
reprendra donna par la francafrique
papier tout jédir francs capitaux de
prix d'entrées de capitaux
regardez au zimbabwe le ministre de la
défense a qualifié la pandémie de
coronavirus de punition divine infligé
aux etats-unis à l'union européenne pour
avoir imposé des sanctions à son pays en
raison de sa répression et de
l'opposition en estonien le ministère de
l'intérieur a déclaré lors d'une
conférence de presse que le rhume avait
été rebaptisée coronavirus et que dans
sa jeunesse
rien de tel n'existe hélas recommandé de
porter des chaussettes chaudes et des
patches de moutarde ainsi que dans le
cadre de la grèce donnera sur la
poitrine comme traitement contre le
virus je voudrais on entend un truc de
ouf ça c'est le ministère de l'intérieur
d' en estonie en irak un leader affirmé
que le coronavirus étaient liés à
l'homosexualité
donc on entend des conneries pas
possible je vous le dis et c'est vrai
que voilà après il ya les extrêmes voilà
qui qui qui voilà qui dit qui y est
dedans on a vu marine le pen ce matin
sur france info qui a été à fond dedans
voilà alors franck frank tapiro est
juste quand les gens disent parce qu'il
ya plein de gens et vous allez voir le
sondage
j'aime montrer tout de suite le sondage
vous allez voir vous allez réagir tout
de suite parce que regarder les
résultats du sondage est ce que vous
pensez que c'est un complot comment la
virus koivu aux théories du complot oui
à 53% nain 47% pour vous dire c'est
quand même énorme ville
tiens toi qui quoi qu'ils croient jeudi
un centre de 400 agents sur et ça
m'étonne pas du tout parce
qu'effectivement on al'impression y
avait un tweet vous le lisiez fort
justement qui disait on nous ment mais
on nous ment tellement nous dit pas la
vérité sur des catastrophes sur tout ce
qui s'est passé sur l'histoire sur le
présent sur l'avenir que vous dites on
s'engouffre dans le vide non on
s'engouffre dans le fait que tout est
possible aujourd'hui dans l'univers dans
le monde dans lequel on vit
et moi je crois qu'effectivement alors
je réfute encore une fois que tous les
complots terrible lente mais semble être
accidentel ça peut être un laboratoire
chinois il ya quelqu'un dire que c'est
dire que c'est accidentel est ce que
c'est un composent que c'était une
personne qui a fait voilà quelques
essais que nous dit la personne là est
ce que ce qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ça franck tapiro mais en fait le
problème il est il est vrai c'est que
les gens ne croient plus en fait en rien
du tout aujourd'hui voilà bon c'est
qu'il prend n'importe quoi ils croient
plus quant au fait religieux
ils croient plus aux politiques regardez
aujourd'hui on prend même heure à la
science on a un génie comme raoult et on
ose encore se demander si c'est un
charlatan pas donc étant donné qu'il n'y
a plus de croyance en rien du tout
la place pour toutes les croyances
possibles et imaginables donc pour moi
c'est parce qu'à une crise de foi
terrible mais par tout le monde et il
faudrait les initialisés cette croyance
réinitialiser la parole publique
si on a plus confiance en la parole
publique alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on va
aller voter etc etc et plus dont là on
va laisser ce genre c'est pas ce genre
de rumeurs se propagent et on va passer
à côté de renforcer la crédibilité du
parole scientifique rôle politique
publique est bien plus sombre a créé ce
genre de choses et légendes finalement
nous croirons rien alors juste je vous
le dis parce que sur twitter il ya plein
de gens qui disent voilà qui croient que
c'est un complot jolie 53% dans l'autre
sont infinies ce que c'est un complot
peul et me sophie koch vous vouliez dire
quoi je vais simplement dire que
s'attaque à la nuque en fait les
scientifiques à la nature parce qu'il
est en fait de deux des pandémies et
avec les catastrophes naturelles
donc on sait pourquoi ça arrive
non moi c'est moi je voudrais je
voudrais quelqu'un là autour l'acquis
qui pense qui croit à la théorie du
complot à part gilles estion nains
autour de la table à non personne
giallorossa y est alors c'est pas que je
prends à la théorie du complot mais ce
que je crois c'est que voulait prendre
la parole non nous laisse el maout elle
comprendre le raisonnement
non mais parce que moi je respecte les
53 % de personnes qui se posent la
question et je pense que si on arrive en
se disant mais nous on a raison on le
sait et on essayait de passer ce message
ça marchera pas simplement
alors est-ce que le pas et quand on sait
pas effectivement il faut trouver les
explications
maintenant la question simple qu'on peut
se poser est ce que ça sert quelqu'un
personne c'est un massacre pour
l'humanité donc quand ça sert personne à
part une pause éventuellement
accidentelle je ne vois pas qui aurait
pu avoir intérêt à fabriquer ce virus
puisque tout le monde est touché toutes
religions toutes nationalités
donc ya pas de raison que ce soit à
viseu viril une certaine partie de la
population
thomas y sont alors je je suis un petit
peu je suis un petit peu gêné parce que
vous venez de dire madame j'aime c'est
vrai vous répondre avec tout le monde je
resterai qui mérite et moi j'interviens
beaucoup dans les écoles j'interviens
beaucoup auprès des plus jeunes auprès
des publics difficiles pour faire un
travail d du cac
média de veille à l'esprit critique et
la première règle qu'on leur donne parce
que si on peut prouver quelque chose
enfin dirons cordialement mais en fait
on parle d'eux
et pourquoi donc parce que finalement
prouvé que quelque chose qui n'existe
n'existe pas c'est pas preuve ça
il rate une heure en fait là la charge
de la preuve elle doit être sur celui
qui dénonce pas sur celui de jason
défend sinon c'est très difficile et
c'est ça devient impossible d'avoir une
discussion mais justement mais vous ne
savez pas plus quand on se fait pas oui
mais quand on sait pas il vaut mieux
écouter la science que des internautes
un petit pas mais c'est aux pèlerins
non mais ce que je ce que je voudrais
juste qu'on se mette d'accord sur le
fait que c'est normal qu'on ne sache pas
le temps que la science travail et
progresse il faut falloir gérer absents
cela les formes de preuves d'un complot
vous savez c'est toujours la même chose
le terrorisme vous n'avez pas entendu
j'ai dit tout le contraire
non mais laurence on va pas d'erreur
appartenir là que je me suis au près
laurent mais j'aimerais juste ya
quelqu'un qui lit thomas lyon est d'une
justesse sans faille ses arguments sont
parfaitement juste il ya quelqu'un qui
vous dit si c'est pas un complot c'est
quoi alors
alors c'est quoi alors bye bye c'est ce
qu'on appelle il sait quoi strophes
cyril une catastrophe c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut pas prévoir avoir des
conséquences terribles
je crois qu'ils le savent il ya quelque
chose qui est horrible pour nous
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut qu'on
accepte l'idée qu'on peut vivre dans un
monde dans lequel il y aurait des
pandémies
ce serait plus facile de vivre dans un
monde dans lequel on pense qu'il ya des
hommes politiques véreux qui créent des
virus pour s'attaquer aux populations
parce que si on se débarrasse des hommes
politiques véreux le monde est génial on
est tous puissent unlock on fume des
pétards
c'est pas ça le vrai monde et je crois
qu'il faut aussi comprendre que quand on
n'arrive pas à répondre à une question
et bien il faut arrêter de dire que
c'est la preuve d'une manipulation
alors y'a qu'a démarré par une question
c'est la preuve qu'on n'arrive pas à
répondre à une question
c'est pas la preuve d'une manipulation
il ya à louis a uni qui nous dit les
complotistes avait prévu la fin du monde
en 2000 smiley
je suis en granit de talent oui en 2012
gilles verdez c'est ce que vous dites ça
parce que vous êtes le syndicat veut
voir à la théorie du complot
oui parce que là on ne parle de
rationalité aucun état ne l'avait prévu
la science ne l'avait pas prévu donc
peut-être qu'il ya un génie du mal
quelque part qui a voulu faire mal à
l'humanité et ça vous allez rire au nez
mais c'est pas si les 53 % des gens qui
pensent qu'il ya un complot organisé ou
qui a peut-être une maladresse d'un
laboratoire c'est parce que on peut se
demander s'il ya des gens qui ont
intérêt comme ça a déclenché des
calamités vous vous allez me dire non
mais qui vous dit que dans dix ans on
n'aura pas raison et on verra pas on la
vérité sortir et que quelqu'un tire à
balle et free ont donné vu la science
est parti mais oui eric vous rigolez
gilles verdez a réussi à mettre d'accord
avec eric naulleau
alors les chéris ya quelqu'un qui dit
s'il vous plaît il ya quelqu'un qui dit
trop de monde sur terre l'économie
mondiale qui va très mal voilà c'est un
débat éternel
eric naulleau qui vous dit ah ça non
mais d'abord 53 % des gens c'est 53 %
des gens qui votent et on sait bien que
c'est les activistes qui veut mais si on
est pas chez nous j'ai répondu non mais
on suivait eric eric chez nous on fait
des débats sur pour ou contre n'oubliez
pas les paroles
et tout le monde vote donc arrêter les
bêtises de nos c'est vrai mais plus là
vous dis des bêtises et plus fervents
défenseurs d'opinions divergentes qui
sont portés à s'exprimer le plus connu
de ces connu après la chaude la deuxième
chose c'est avec des raisonnements
pareils qu'est ce que vous dites à des
gamins qui nous explique la théorie des
illuminati il faut respecter toutes les
opinions ne rien et on ne rien répondre
de rassurer parce qu'on est du côté de
poids des sachant qu'il faut pas et
qu'il faut tout le temps verser dans la
démagogie c'est de la démagogie que des
gens veuillent le croire de bonne foi
vous parce qu'ils ont intérêt à le faire
par comprendre et que des gens sensés
par pure démagogie comme laurence ou
s'il s'est livré de l'eau agence vous
l'aï dit il faut pas complètement
irresponsable alain elle a pas dit ça du
tout non mais j'ai pas dit ça dans l'os
mais non vous parlerai tout à l'heure
j'ai dit justement il n'y avait aucune
raison parce que ça touche toute
l'humanité alors merci de retenir hp
pour les comprenez
il faudrait qu'on fasse tout en algérie
vraiment tu veux réagir parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui nous disent sans que
ce soit un complot est ce qu'on peut
croire en un accident de laboratoire
ça c'est une vraie question il y en a
tellement johnson qui nous disent à
l'exemple et alors on vous attendait les
mots tu démontes que c'est que ces
d'origine animale il suffisait de
regarder ce soir encore une fois le le
médecin spécialiste du figaro dans le jt
de france 2 qui expliquait on a la
preuve que ça vient d'origine animale et
quoique après quoi la preuve
scientifique là dessus y a pas du tout
de doutes de la communauté scientifique
sur cette question de quel animal
oui mais ça vient d'origine animale sein
d'un laboratoire
c'est donc c'est sûr on peut
complètement exclue pas sans bon sens
des scientifiques aujourd'hui les
regards sont des dizaines l'auto leur
nom mais il faut juste posons les faits
toute attente alors il ya aussi il ya
des gens qui disent beaucoup dire que
beaucoup disent que c'est pour remettre
le système bancaire à 0 et faire une
refonte totale
c'est frank tapiro c'est une colonie
saint ouen chiche mais encore une fois
ça fait partie de toutes les conneries
qu'on entend depuis tout à l'heure c'est
tout est possible tout est possible on
allait bien donc on sait que les gens
pensent contextuel ils se disent
forcément il ya une raison il peut pas y
avoir en ennemis qui est beaucoup de
l'ordre du hasard monsieur lazhar est
très compliqué on va entendre le bain
encore une fois comme on l'a dit ça
tombe bien juste un peu la discussion
c'est leur retraite parce que c'est
qu'ils partent
etc etc quand on voit autant de
conneries à la seconde et qu'on voit de
plus en plus de gens y croient moi je me
pose souvent cette question de venir
mais finalement il ya un plan sagittal
heures la nature a horreur du vide
vivement que la science ils montrent que
les politiques s'entendent sur des
raisons sur des causes pour donner des
explications
tant qu'il n'y a pas d'explication
fiable malheureusement on aura tous les
jours ce genre de complot c'est qui est
terrible on a on ne suis plus confiante
senti vraiment tu voulais réagir as-tu
tout ce que tu as entendu ou pas parce
que vraiment à vue tu as vu le sondage
53% des gens qui nous regardent pense
que c'est ils sont ok avec la théorie du
complot mais n'entendent et bien non pas
ouais pari fou mais ça va zy est en fait
moi je peux comprendre les 53% parce
qu'en fait on a nos
politique qui nous balade dans tous les
sens on s'est laissés là que les gens te
disent un complot on a un médicament qui
a été la chloroquine là par exemple qui
a été créée de temps les deux pays
depuis les années 40 il a tout arrêté en
vente libre
et comme par hasard comme ça boîtes de
cachets à 2 euros
on l'a interdite la vente c'est at on
pas loin et motos marée basse allemand
thomas thomas thomas thomas husson super
temps à répondre vraiment vraiment la
neige les défis lyon raymond juste où tu
démontres cours on leur dit pas vraiment
on t'entend pas bien raymond l'estomac
répondre qu'on ne va pas bien
ecoutez-moi écoutez-moi remo au moins
d'octobre une commission indépendante a
décidé de placer la chloroquine sur la
liste des médicaments sur ordonnance
c'est ce truc là y rentrer en
application au début du mois de janvier
ça n'a rien à voir avec une décision qui
aurait été prise en lien avec la
pandémie et en l'occurrence il se trouve
que la chloroquine est un médicament qui
était pas obligatoire mention ordonnance
mais qui était donné dans plus de 90%
des cas sur eure 2 nantes avec une
prescription médicale
très précieux et juste pour préciser
pour les gens qui nous écoutent
c'est pas la chloroquine qui serait
efficace d'après le professeur à ou
contre le coronavirus mais la
combinaison de la chloroquine et d'un
autre médicament dans des conditions
très particulières
vous savez je crois qu'il ya quand même
quelque chose qui que cette discussion
ne montre bien c'est que sur les
questions scientifiques il faut être
extrêmement précis il faut écouter des
gens qui sont des spécialistes de ces
questions là et au maximum essayez de
garder une forme de mesure
il ya quelque chose qui est très
désagréable aujourd'hui parce que on a
tous peur de cette maladie des fois
accepter qu'il y ait un tout petit peu
d'incertitude qui est liée au temps de
la recherche
le temps de la recherche c'est pas le
temps des réseaux sociaux
j'ai alors y'a plein de il ya plein de
gens ne s'attendaient pas vraiment
autant très mal donc entreprendre adoma
mon raymond juste les chéris si c'est
pas un complot pourquoi tout le monde
est contre le professeur raoul la chine
devrait payer pour les dégâts causés par
pour ce vide par ce virus
la première firme pharmaceutique qui va
sortir le vaccin jackpot c'est pour cela
qu'il flingue le professeur raoul tout
ça il ya plein il ya plein de twitts
actuelle qui peut répondre très
rapidement en trop souvent à sa porte
alors sur house est quand même
extraordinaire à satee 20 ans 25 ans ce
type est une sommité française et
mondiale internationale ou ne
connaissait pas c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille à marseille sur la technologie
est là il sort une petite phrase en
disant qu'il a un traitement prometteur
est un scientifique c'est un expert
mondial reconnu dans le monde entier il
parle traitement prometteur il se fait
tomber dessus
partout on ose même dire que c'est
peut-être un charlatan moi je vous fais
il est devenu fou si la parole n'a plus
de sens il faut écouter ceux qui savent
et ceux qui savent c'est pas vous c'est
pas moi on n'est pas médecin
ce sont des chercheurs des scientifiques
dont c'est le métier et l'expertisé donc
ravoux sait pas qu'il faut défendre ou
dire que ce sont cinq mois le meilleur
et c'est au monde avoir confiance en ce
qu'il dit ce mec n'est pas fou il est
scientifique pour que le monde entier
moi ce qui me choque c'est star est
commun après 34 ans passés même qu'ils
le soient merci merci je remarque que le
père thomas la place du professeur out
aujourd'hui ouais le professeur out
c'est un chercheur il a une piste qui
semble prometteuse pour soigner le
coronavirus et je pense que tout le
monde a très envie que cette piste
fonctionne tranquillement ce majorité
des médecins envie que ça fonctionne il
faut juste qu'implique le professeur
raoul et pas rejetée par les
institutions ayant communication presque
quotidiennes avec le gouvernement
français
il faisait partie du groupe de recherche
des manuels macron sur la maladie non
mais le professeur out fait quelque part
il a été dépossédé de sa propre
recherche il a été placé par des tas de
gens sur internet comme une espèce de
dieu qui devrait vaincre la maladie
le professeur à outils un scientifique
qui travaille qui fait un travail très
difficile et on verra si son travail
donne les résultats que nous espérons
tout ce qu'ils peuvent donner
après il faut quand même constaté
quelque chose c'est que ben voilà en
avant un peu le professeur à oman pour
le reste du monde c'est pas la réalité
le prochain roman hawaï avec des
médecins
qui respecte son travail et peut-être
qu'à la fin de l'année ce motion al prix
nobel est effectivement ils vont aller
votre gazinière si novès
exactement c'est pour ça qu'on espère
qu'il aura